putin ist schlagbar aber nur wenn wir
ihn wenn wir die ukrainische Seite
weiter unterstützen deswegen bin ich bei
allen die gesagt haben konzentrieren wir
uns doch jetzt auf das was wir ändern
können worauf wir Einfluss haben und wir
haben konkret nur auf eines Einfluss der
Ukraine zu helfen denn wir haben einen
verängstigten Putin erlebt so habe ich
das zumindestens wahrgenommen der zum
allerersten Mal den Eindruck erweckte er
sei zu Verhandlungen bereit bei dem
offenkundig das Wasser bis zum Hals
stand also wenn wir wirklich die Ukraine
stärker machen und mehr Druck ausüben
dann könnte das dazu führen dass auch
schon unter Putin Verhandlungen
eingeleitet werden können die er
sicherlich nicht zum Abschluss bringen
wird aber das könnte das Ende dieses
furchtbaren kriege